allez
people mic les yeux humoristes qui
balance sur LoL polémique
souvent ensemble elles se moque de moi
systématiquement je la fais chanter
parce que c'est people limites polémique
te dit mais oui parce que c'est pas le
dire j'arrive tu es gentil toi
pipolémique avec pour une fois que tu
arrives à prononcer un mot celui-ci
allez on y va on passe tout de suite là
il faut les mixte
de la semaine faudrait que j'ai mis
habitué allez l'humoriste blanche Gardin
vous la connaissez je l'adore déjà
disons-le bon elle avait balancé sur les
réseaux sociaux Isa va nous en faire une
heure avec ça je pipolémique
l'humoriste mange gardien avait balancé
sur les réseaux sociaux qu'elle avait
été contacté par Amazon évidemment pour
participer à la prochaine saison de LoL
Kiri sort j'adore sauf qu'elle a
expliqué avoir refusé elle a surtout
balancé combien on lui proposait ce à
quoi plusieurs humoristes ont décidé de
réagir et ça a provoqué un très gros
débat récemment c'est Florence Foresti
qui s'en est mêlé on regarde le récap et
vous me dites peut-être ce que vous en
pensez
hello elle qui ressort c'est le
programme d'humour qui cartonne sur
Amazon Prime pour sa troisième saison 3
ça commence maintenant porter par un
casting 5 étoiles grâce à la puissance
de la plateforme l'émission fait
également énormément parler d'elle en ce
moment à cause d'une vilaine polémique
l'humoriste blanche Gardin a fait le
buzz en révélant avoir refusé de
participer au chaud malgré les 200 000
euros qu'on lui aurait proposé pour une
seule journée de travail très très cher
Monsieur Bezos je suis au regret de
devoir refuser votre invitation à
participer à la prochaine saison du jeu
lol qui resort j'ai bien compris qu'il
ne s'agissait que d'une seule journée de
tournage seulement voilà ce jour-là j'ai
dentiste l'humoriste ne s'est pas arrêté
à ce simple refus puisque dans ce long
poste sur ses réseaux sociaux elle s'est
lancée dans une diatribe contre le géant
américain oui ça me gêne de toucher pour
8h de travail cette somme affolante de
la part d'une entreprise qui ne paye pas
ses impôts en France qui émet 55,8
millions de tonnes de gaz à effet de
serre par an et qui utilisent la main
d'oeuvre des camps de concentration
ouigo seulement voilà cette sortie
médiatique n'a pas été du goût de tout
le monde Ahmed Sylla et Florence Foresti
entre autres son moto au créneau cette
dernière a même publié une vidéo
hilarant de son chien a priori très
fâché contre Amazon très fâché contre
Amazon Albert salut société qui
consommation tu as dégoûte et bien
qu'elle ne prononce pas son nom dans la
vidéo l'attaque contre l'humoriste
anti-amazon semble clair et limpide
alors selon vous Florence Foresti
a-t-elle bien fait de ta clé blanche
Gardin
[Musique]
les amis qui est pour qui est contre oui
non alors je veux d'abord un contre
Laurent
de dénoncer ça a répondu avec beaucoup
d'humour comme souvent un truc drôle à
la polémique du moment voilà la vraie
question c'est est-ce que Blanche Gardin
a raison de refuser cette proposition
incroyable moi je suis étonné que
personne s'étonne des sommes quand même
on est quand même sur une série
franco-française autant quand tu fais
une série sur Amazon qui va être
internationale tu fais le que le revival
de Friends tu sais que tu peux filer des
millions de dollars ça va être vu par
des millions et millions de personnes là
ce programme il est regardé que par les
francophones
pour une journée et il paraît-il la
chose ce serait un million hein
mais ça cartonné les enfants
j'ai du mal à avoir Amazon investir un
million six puisqu'ils sont huit
candidats mais oui 2000 chacun un
million un million 6 pour peut-être
faire que 5 minutes dans l'émission
parce que si tu te marres en fait
quelle est la question
blanche Gardin un cas des non c'est ça
qui a touché 200000 balles elle veut pas
toucher 200000 balles parce qu'elle
critique elle a eu raison la société
Amazon qui a été emploie des ouigo et
cetera la question c'est oui d'accord
avec Blanche Gardin ça c'est vrai
qu'elle a eu raison de dénoncer ça et
voilà alors
moi alors blanche Gardin c'est
l'humoriste pour moi la plus spirituelle
la plus drôle la plus petite la plus
hilarante qui existe non mais vraiment
elle peut tout faire passer quoi c'est
des proches au féminin elle est
magnifique le fait en fait qu'elle est
dénoncée qu'elle essaie convictions là
c'est fantastique elle est assez tu me
l'as suivi elle a ses convictions c'est
merveilleux le seul truc le hic c'est
qu'en fait là le problème c'est que ça
la dessert parce que elle passe malgré
tout ici je trouve pour une donneuse de
leçons parce que qu'est-ce que ça veut
dire ça veut dire qu'en fait tous ceux
qui ont accepté ce sont des banques sont
des pauvres non c'est même pas que ça
culpabilise c'est que ça veut dire toi
en fait tu n'as pas de conscience tu as
une conscience au niveau du Zéro voilà
ce que ça veut dire pour tous les autres
il faut quand même des faut quand même
des stars les Gad Elmaleh etc vous ne
vous posez pas de questions
voilà moi ce que je trouve c'est que en
France avec ce genre de choses on a un
problème avec l'argent donc je suis pas
d'accord avec le avec Laurent dans la
mesure où de toute façon ces acteurs ces
chanteurs etc il est très très grande
somme pour d'autres activités qui sont
pas forcément toujours plus nobles que
celle là ça c'est un concept qui a une
dizaine d'années qui a été lancé au
Japon je crois qu'il fonctionne bien il
y a des salaires à l'étranger qui sont
beaucoup plus élevés
par tête il y en a qui sont à beaucoup
moins je crois que c'est 30-40 50000
donc voilà ça dépend aussi de qui tu es
d'autre et puis c'est un programme aussi
qui a évolué quand tu vois que cette
année tu as pierres ni les Adèle
exerceau boulot
peut-être d'affiche du cinéma français
ça veut dire qu'il faut se les payer
c'est quand même des superstar aussi
voilà c'est des superstars
c'est normal en fait l'émission Philippe
ça m'a bien fait rigoler mais là où
c'est quand même hyper cousu de la part
de Blanche Gardin c'est que c'est quand
même un petit milieu et que en dénonçant
six camarades qui sont passés juste
avant je pense qu'elle s'est quand même
grillé pour pas mal de films à venir et
d'ailleurs Marion Cotillard et Camille
Cottin qui était prévu normalement pour
la saison 4 après cette petite polémique
ce sont tout au tout se sont retirés
également parce qu'ils savent aussi que
ça descend des sommes qu'on leur a
proposé ils le savent ils sont un peu
honteux voilà et c'est pas 200000 balles
pour le faire tu le fais ou pas bien sûr
oui parce que moi je suis un charclos je
gagne mais oui ils avaient pas besoin de
ça ils sont déjà tous riches etc et
200000 je suis désolé si la France est
une poudrière aujourd'hui c'est aussi
parce que il y a des inégalités sont
trop favoris volumique
[Musique]
ils sont riches justement parce qu'ils
sont accepté des sommes comme ça pour
faire certaines choses
une journée de 100000 €. quand tu peux
faire comprendre ça quelqu'un qui
travaille toute la journée pour de 100 €
par jour ou 500 €. attention on oublie
de dire que pour les voleurs les actions
caritatives
prendre les 200000 € et partager dans
des associations ça aurait été classe ça
aussi plutôt péter tous ses camarades
notamment sur Twitter évidemment sur les
réseaux sociaux on écoute que tout de
même ce qu'a dit Ahmed Sylla sur NRJ
ou pas tu es gentil tu es un peu poussé
les curseurs ma chérie
mais j'ai pas trouvé ça cool le sapin
blanche parce qu'elle a fait parce que
ça jette un peu l'eau propre sur nous
tous nous autres genre nous on a ceux
qui nous ont fait c'est un peu je base
tous ceux qui avaient accepté vous êtes
un peu euh un peu gainage je suis un peu
mieux que vous quoi c'est pas hyper cool
j'ai pas compris on lui a proposé les
200 à la dîner
au lieu de lui a pas proposé ça c'est
pas c'est mon temps là
tu dis un demi million là je dis ok je
vais faire ma gueule
moi j'ai reçu un bâtila à la radio à RFM
il a pas voulu en parler
ils sont jeunesse
maintenant moi
je trouve vraiment quelqu'un de propre
et donc
du cinéma il a il a vraiment c'est vrai
que ça jette au propre
quand il s'agit d'un footballeur ou d'un
ou d'un sportif enfin je veux je vois
pas pourquoi
ce sont des sommes astronomiques
c'est la terre entière vous connaissez
les les les les non pas du tout pas du
tout mais sur certaines séries les
salaires des comédiens etc c'est énorme
là ils ont quand même une actrice qui
est césarisé ils avaient Virginie Efira
qui vient de recevoir un César ils l'ont
dans un programme c'est Amazon Amazon
ils sont pété de thunes c'est un groupe
voilà elle a donné les chiffres
et puis surtout toutes ces personnes là
ils ont cédé leur droit d'image
c'est-à-dire que vous pouvez les
regarder en replay et regarder une fois
deux fois trois fois etc donc ça ça se
paye aussi la raison sur un exemple
on oublie juste
[Rires]
c'est une ponctuation sur Internet
on oublie juste le sens du message de
Blanche Gardin que j'aurais défendre un
petit peu au final parce que pour une
fois que quelqu'un mais en lien ces
actes avec ses idées et au moins
refusent des trucs on devrait dire juste
bravo Madame bien sûr et deuxièmement
n'oubliez pas quand même que ce qu'elle
dit et c'est clair elle s'attaque pas au
programme et ça date pas assez camarades
elle s'attaque au groupe Amazon CNS
c'est normal tu crois en zone lui dit eh
200000 t'es ok pour une journée bah dis
donc elle explique pourquoi moi je
trouve ça les impôts en France aussi
malgré ce qui a été dit ils sont obligés
les enfants on va conclure
c'est que par exemple effectivement
il fait des trucs avec Netflix parce que
le cinéma strictosu ne plus les moyens
de se payer au marché donc si c'est pas
adosser une plateforme genre Netflix ça
n'est plus possible
allez les amis
ne t'énerve pas ma chérie tu sais que
c'est pas bon pour ton cœur